[Music]
just three episodes in the new season of
the smash
disney plus hit the mandalorian has
continued to see mando
and the child exploring parts yet unseen
in the galaxy far far away
it's also found them encountering
creatures too frightful to mention for
those who fear things with more than
four legs
chapter 11 of the mandalorian thankfully
took a bit of a break from the creature
feature fantasia that dominated the
first two episodes
well sort of titled the heiress the
latest entry in mando's quest
to return the child to his people saw
the duo hitting the high seas
and indeed running into yet another
beastly foe
luckily mando also ran into some people
of his own as he and the child are
helped out of their jam
by a band of mandalorian allies while
this episode of the mandalorian
expands the world of the
weapon-worshiping religious sect in
fascinating new ways
the arrival of those helmet-issuing
allies undoubtedly delighted die-hard
star wars fans
because there are some very familiar
clone wars names involved
chief among this is beau katan who
featured prominently in the beloved
animated series as the head of house
pries
and former regent of mandalore what are
you waiting for
get out there
she was also the one time wielder of the
darksaber
whose history she also details in the
heiress while star wars fans were no
doubt elated to hear the story
and see bo katan in the flesh they were
likely just as happy to see the face of
the actor portraying the fearsome
warrior
as she also voiced the character in the
animated series her name is katie
sakhoff and any true sci-fi fan should
be quite familiar with her face
here's why beau katan from the
mandalorian looks so familiar
if you do call yourself a true sci-fi
fan katie sakhoff's face is probably
familiar to you
because it was often front and center on
one of the best
loved sci-fi programs of the past two
decades that series was ronald d
moore's utterly brilliant modern update
of the classic sci-fi soccer battlestar
galactica
which found the last remnants of
humanity on the run from a murderous
race of man-made android enemies
and in desperate search of a fabled
planet that may serve as mankind's new
home
i've been to earth
i know where it is the series premiered
on sci-fi back in 2004
and quickly became a massive hit with
both fans of the original 1970s show
and those who had never heard of adama
apollo cylons or viper fighters
even if they'd never heard those names
it's possible they had heard the name
starbuck before
not only from the pages of hermann
melville's iconic novel moby dick
but also because the hot shot viper
pilot's name was probably the most
prominent to arise from the original
battlestar galactica series
portrayed by dirk benedict in the
original series starbuck got a much
needed modernizing for the sci-fi series
reboot
with more transforming the cocksure
pilot into a fearsome femme
the likes of which sci-fi fans had never
really seen before
and yes katie sakhoff was the actor
tasked with resurrecting the character
for the new battlestar galactica to
simply say she did that would be a gross
understatement though
more than any actor in the series zakhov
didn't just
resurrect her character she wholly
reinvented it
delivering what can only be described as
a towering performance almost too
big even for the epic series around it
of course if you somehow slept on
battlestar galactica over the years it's
possible you recognize sackoff from a
plethora of other notable small screen
turns as the actor has also appeared on
the likes of longmire
24 and most recently netflix's another
life
she also turned up in a certain cw
aeroverse hit as
one of dc comics toughest underground
kingpins
that arrowverse hit is none other than
the flash which means the underground in
question belongs to barry allen's
hometown of central city
and yes that was indeed katie sakhoff
portraying the nefarious amunet black
on the hit cw drama a meta human with
significant power
ammunite black was the premier dealer of
weaponizing tech on central city's black
market
and therefore supplied many of team
flash's foes with the destructive tools
of their villainous trades
in turn ammunite black's business
dealings more often than not put her in
direct
conflict with barry and his allies in
spite of her prominent role
in the central city underworld sakhov's
character appeared in just
six episodes of the flash during its
seven season run on the cw
most of which came in the series fourth
season but even in such a limited
capacity
sakoff more than made her mark on the
series crafting a villainous as ruthless
relentless
and delightfully devious as any that has
ever faced off against barry and his
due-gooding gang
even if the character doesn't always get
the respect she so richly deserves
while katie sakhoff has largely made her
name on television
the actor has managed to rack up some
impressive big screen credits over the
years
she actually got her first big break
after landing a key role in 2002's
flawed but fun halloween sequel
halloween resurrection
and a sense appeared in genre delights
like 2013's riddick and 2016's gothic
chiller don't knock twice
if you want to see katie sackoff at her
big screen best however
look no further than the 2013 creeper
she made with mike flanagan
yes that mike flanagan the very genre
mastermind behind such modern horror
classics is hush
gerald's game dr sleep and netflix's
breathtaking the haunting of hill house
series
before delivering those frightful
delights to the masses flanagan actually
scored a modest hit with a little
haunted mirror creeper by the name of
oculus
it's understandable if the term haunted
mirror made you cringe a little
and the initial setup of flanagan's
oculus which follows a woman attempting
to clear her brother of murder charges
by proving the culprit was actually the
haunted artifact in question
really is a bit silly but if flanagan
has proven anything over the years it's
that he can turn even the silliest of
premises
into a soul-stirring and genuinely
terrifying cinematic treat
that's just what flanagan does with
oculus delivering a haunted mirror
marvel that simply has
no business being as effective as it is
flanagan bolsters the film's impact by
pulling brilliant turns from his cast
including karen gillen
brenton thwaites rory cochrane and a
never better katie sakhoff as the
tragically departed family matriarch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you